le 26 septembre prochain l'allemagne
organise des élections législatives un
scrutin à l'issue duquel angela merkel
quittera le pouvoir après plus de 15 ans
passés à la chancellerie elles sont
candidats de la cdo armin laschet pts
est passé à l'offensive s'est en tout
cas l'analyse et des médias allemands au
lendemain du premier débat télévisé
entre trois candidats le problème le
candidat conservateur est à la traîne
dans les sondages est le social
démocrate olaf scholz a devancé
l'écologiste anna lena bareback
reléguant armin l'achète en troisième
position écoutez justement à les
précisions de notre correspondant à
berlin peter oliver
suite au premier débat de ce site
électorale entre les candidats à la
chancellerie allemande nous n'avons pas
vraiment de gagnant clair mais nous
avons un gagnant tout de même
c'est du parti social démocrate
après le débat le public est sondé pour
savoir qu'il aura le plus +
36 % ont dit olaf scholz du parti social
démocrate fiona l'ena bare bow parti
vert à 30% l'hermine la chaîne de
l'union conservatrice en troisième place
avec 25% des voix
il a été très offensif lors de ce débat
il le fallait car sa cote de popularité
personnelle est vraiment en baisse 7 ans
si les pronostics ont longtemps fait de
lui l'héritier présomptif dans gala
merkel qu'il ait sa place pour cette
élection mais son comportement lors de
plusieurs occasions il n'y a pas gagné
les faveurs des allemands
lors du débat il a ciblé olaf scholz et
le parti social-démocrate demandant si
et s'engager à ne pas former de
coalition avec l'extrême gauche
il a également affirmé que le parti
écologiste et leur politique mettait en
danger l'emploi allemand notamment dans
l'industrie
une des raisons de cette combativité
et son manque de popularité auprès des
allemands
si nous nous remémorons les inondations
tragiques dans l'est du pays y compris
en rhénanie du nord westphalie
la région dont il est le président il a
été filmé lors d'un discours du
président allemand frank walter
steinmeier en train de rire et de
plaisanter
alors que de monsieur stand mayer
faisait part de ses condoléances et
promettez des soutiens financiers à ceux
qui avaient tout perdu
ça nous renvoie pas une belle image ça
ne fait pas bon joint
cette posture agressive de monsieur
l'achète n'a pas fonctionné auprès du
public mais il ne s'est pas davantage
enferré
olaf chose qui mène d'un cheveu dans les
sondages de popularité pour le rôle de
chancelier n'a pas commis de faux pas
dimanche soir
il est actuellement ministre des
finances et vice chancelier des
représentants du partenaire mineur de la
coalition gouvernementale
il n'a pas pris de risque et n'a pas
commis d'erreur
anna-lena bareback du parti vert est
plus populaire à titre personnel que son
parti en général elle a particulièrement
brillé sur les impôts les subventions
pour les foyers à faibles revenus mais
certains soient davantage de garanties
sur jusqu'en le parti vert pourrait
alors en matière de politique climatique
en fin de compte cependant les
chanceliers ne sont pas élus sur leurs
résultats lors d'un débat
les partis eux mêmes sont déterminants
et les sondages placent les
sociaux-démocrates en tête à 24
l'union conservatrice à 21% et les verts
7%
cela signifie qu'aucun parti n'a
suffisamment de voix pour former une
coalition gouvernementale à deux
partenaires il faudra au moins trois
parties et cela présage de négociation
très longue et très compliqué
peut-être attendre un certain temps
avant d'avoir un nouveau chancelier un
remplaçant il a marqué
10 à la chancellerie se retrouveront
lors de débats les 9 septembre avant les
élections